Out there in the cosmic abyss are objects
like stars, galaxies and planets.
They can coexist peacefully … but sometimes,
a star might look so tantalizing, its neighbor
will want to eat it.
*MUNCH*
White dwarfs are very dense stars, comparable
in mass to our Sun.
These stars are at the end of their lives
and can no longer produce any energy on their
own to survive.
So when gravity pushes a white dwarf next
to an energy producing star, it makes its
move.
Using its strong gravitational pull, the white
dwarf will suck up the outer gas layers of
a star.
Those gases are essentially star food.
In one instance, a white dwarf devoured 90%
of a star’s mass, turning it into a brown
dwarf.
Brown dwarfs are considered failed stars because
they can’t shine as brightly.
Basically another star sucked the life out
of it.
This isn’t just something that happens with
stars.
Our nearest neighbor, the Andromeda galaxy,
is also a space predator.
Stars and dwarf galaxies that get too close
to Andromeda have reportedly been consumed!
And Andromeda is heading our way.
The Milky Way and Andromeda galaxy are moving
towards each other at about 75 miles per second.
It'll take billions of years, but Andromeda
will eventually swallow us whole.
*gasp* Creating a super-giant galaxy.
Ultimately, the stars and galaxies can’t
help it, cosmic cannibalism comes down to
gravity.
It’s a star eat star world out there.
*MUNCH*
You can watch new episodes of Space Crafts
right here every Wednesday!
And for more on star siblings, check out this
video to learn about the family tree for the
stars in our Galaxy.
Thanks for watching and make sure to subscribe!